you'll soon notice an issue with our set
up if we walk through our entities and
render them in the list as they've been
allocated then we get into situations
that some objects will render above or
below other objects which may cause
visual issues for instance explosions
should draw above everything else but
with our current setup this won't happen
depending on how our entity list is
sorted the classic solution of this
problem is to introduce a z-index
property to each entity that describes
in what order an object should be
rendered if we assume the map is at Z
and X equal to 0 then our engine will
draw entities with lower Z indexes first
such that they appear underneath objects
with higher ZZ order values once we've
added the Z index value to each of our
entities we have to modify the game
engine classes draw function to take
this into account so looking at the code
here first our draw function will of
course go through and draw the map then
as before we walk through each of our
entities and if it's within our view
wrecked we render it to the screen now
your job is to figure out how to modify
this code so that we properly render
taking z-index into account